le drapeau de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique
IC devant cette centrale du sud-ouest de
l'Ukraine un moment symbolique qui
marque le début d'une présence
permanente des experts de l'Agence dans
le pays
nous laissons un groupe d'experts qui
vont rester ici de façon permanente et
il lancera de même dans toutes les
autres centrales où nous travaillerons
main dans la main avec nos autres
ukrainien
nous nous assurons que ces installations
si importantes pour le pays en
particulier dans ces temps difficiles
continuent à fonctionner normalement et
sans aucun problème
le planning normalisé
concrètement des experts vont être
déployés par groupe de deux dans toutes
ses centrales nucléaires ukrainiennes
Ukraine du Sud rivenaient ski mais aussi
Tchernobyl la seule qui n'est plus en
activité depuis la catastrophe en 1986
des membres de l'agence sont déjà
installés à zapporja la plus grande
centrale du pays contrôle et par les
troupes russes une nouvelle équipe de
trois personnes est arrivée cette
semaine pour remplacer la précédente la
mission sur place est suivie de près par
les autorités ukrainiennes nous
retournerons à la centrale nucléaire de
zaporigia ce n'est qu'une question de
temps
mais la question clé
est très importante dont nous avons
parlé c'est l'état dans lequel nous
retrouverons notre centrale et ici la
mission de l'IEA est très importante
elle regardera ce qu'il se passe là bas
les actions qui sont prises concernant
notre site la situation reste précaire à
saporidja ou les six réacteurs sont à
l'arrêt l'alimentation en électricité
reste fragile la dernière ligne
électrique a subi plusieurs déconnexions
la semaine dernière pourtant elle est
indispensable notamment pour assurer la
sûreté du site